Have you ever gotten a flat or had to patch a hole in your bike tire?
Well, that may be a thing of the past if designer Brian Russell's...
...airless and puncture proof tires get licensed.
Britek Tire and Rubber, Russell's Colorado company,...
...has spent years working on an airless tire for automobiles,...
...but have shifted its attention recently to bike tires.
The concept, named "Energy Return Wheel" or ERW,...
..."uses rubber that's stretched over a series of carbon...
...nanotube-reinforced composite rods to provide cushioning.
These rods can be adjusted to change the tension in the tire to suit different terrain."
The company hopes to literally "reinvent the wheel" by...
...providing tires that are not only puncture proof and airless,...
...but provide a more even and efficient ride.
Designers are contemplating adding sidewalls on the bike tires...
...so that mud and dirt will not plug up the frame.
The design is still currently in the prototype phase,...
...and the company notes that they are looking for...
...companies and sponsors to help in licensing the product.
What do you think of the airless tire concept?